and i always say that the worst thing
about a virgo is you're um
you're an overachiever and so you do
achieve great things
yet the the virgo element doesn't allow
you to feel it
and and believe it and acknowledge
yeah that's the hardest part so i always
wonder if it's
worse to achieve great things and not
feel it or just not achieve them but
feel like you whatever you did was
baller
right yes i totally have actually
thought of this before
like what's the better reality to live
in because you do live in your own
reality and it's like yeah what reality
would you want to paint for yourself
like i don't know so it's interesting
yeah so the perfectionism resonates with
you
the analytics the
practical the credit like what were you
thinking of when i said that
um yes there are definitely parts it's
funny i feel like i um i'm like split in
half
and um i'm a very like like in one side
i'm super free-spirited and just like
fun-loving and then there's this other
very strong half of me that's very like
goal-oriented
perfectionistic like has to achieve
always analyzing and like you know
like you said not always seeing the
value in like what i've done and
so it's funny i feel like i have these
two like battling sides of myself
and at different times of my life i've
been like
you know this side's gotten stronger and
then this side's stronger so it's like
hmm you know uh the other thing is
you grew up in arizona i live in
scottsdale oh no way yes
arizona girl through uh i was grew up in
gilbert
yeah do you miss it i do i love it there
and my mom
and one of my sisters still lives there
and so that's kind of always going to be
like home base for our family
um because that's where we always go for
christmases and
you know it's it'll always be like home
and i love that it's just a quick
car ride away like i can literally just
on a whim be like i'm going to see my
mom
like jump in my car and be in arizona um
because you're probably in la right yeah
whenever i drive to la or laguna or
anywhere out that direction i always
drive too i mean it's imaginable that i
would drive probably based on my past
but
um but yeah yeah yeah such an easy drive
and i feel like i just you know cruise
this traffic at about 95 which always is
nice
yeah put some good tunes listen to an
audio book or something and get to like
kind of check out for a little bit
you know rather than yeah dealing with
the airport which takes about the same
amount of time anyway once you've like
done the whole thing
exactly okay well if you were gonna be
on a car ride
on your own for six hours what what what
is it that you're putting on or what
have you put on recently
to pass the time when you've driven
let's see last time i
drove i listened to some of daring
greatly from brene brown
it's one of my favorite books of all
time i feel like it's something i need
to read
every few years to like just put myself
in a
like every time i read it i'm like yes i
just feel like i understand like my
relationship with the world a little
better and a little less personally
and so i love that book so i read that
last time i was going and i would
intersperse it with like just
today's hot uh top hits playlist to like
you know when i'd start to get sleepy
from like you know
self-help book world will do that to you
totally and i'd start to get sleepy i'd
be like all right trying to put on some
of the new
top hits of today and and like let's go
yes all the way like oh i have to try to
keep up with this stuff sometimes i'm
like i have no idea what the hits are
and i'm like i should know this stuff
i'm a musician this is my
this is my world well i mean that's
actually i just thought how fascinating
it is like just you know i'm sure
you've been asked a ton of times what
you listen to for music but
you know playing the violin and having
that be sort of
more of like a i don't it's not really
classical but it's kind of classical
right like how would you categorize it
it's instrumental it's
uh classical instrumental like new age
vibe well i mean the violin is like such
a
classical instrument but i do not play
it in a classical way
at all like it's funny how you know i
still like
i've saw my sheet music right here i
still practice classical music
to try to like keep up on that skill
level because there's nothing that will
get your chops good as much as like
class music but it's just a totally
different way of playing and i don't
even
call myself a classical violinist
because i have so much respect
for like that art is something different
and what i do is just kind of this
mixture of different sounds and tunes
very new age um
but just using the violin as my voice
yeah and your body i mean because you're
you know with dancing and moving i mean
like that
there's absolutely a transmission of
information
with that too and what i i think is
crazy is that
how you ended up being able to come back
around
in your life from being told as a child
that you need to pick either
dance or violin was that difficult or
was it easy at that point
um i was six years old
and so you know and i definitely
understand it wasn't my parents being
like you can't do this it was like
we literally can't afford to give you
either
and like i understood to a certain
extent that like
i didn't really understand that we had
money problems but i understood it you
know what i mean
um and so being a young kid that's
actually one of the reasons i practiced
so hard was because i knew that if i
didn't practice
my mom was not going to keep paying for
lessons that i did not
practice for like they just did not have
the money to invest into some
kid that was wasting their lessons it
wasn't like he will play the violin
i had to earn that um but you know so
when i was
told i had to pick like they took me to
a dance class and they took me to a
violin lesson and they were like
all right which one do you want to do
you know the rest of your life basically
um and i think i was just so darn
intimidated in the dance class because
like there was all these other girls and
they knew
the little warm-up exercises and so i
was like i'll do the violin
like it was a private lesson i was by
myself no one was looking at me
you know so but my whole life i've just
always
wanted to dance i remember i even
auditioned my
best friend and i from high school laugh
about it that we auditioned for the high
school dance team and we had no business
being in that room like we'd laugh about
it
because we like made fools of ourselves
because we just wanted to dance you know
and of course we didn't make it
um and then it wasn't until i was in
college that i thought well why can't i
like
at least move and express with the
violin like i can do that and it just
has grown from there
wow so it wasn't until much later that
the dancing came
yes like and it's funny people like kind
of assume that i you know was a dancer
and then
combined with violin but like absolutely
not like in college i
had never danced in my life and i just
started to like i said it was just
starting with like movement and then i
was like
look i started to learn about like foot
placement and
oh that's called first position like oh
you turn out interesting
you know so i started to learn like the
proper form and but it was all
self-taught